remember that terrible movie we did
remember the worst movie in the world we
did i i mean i had fun i had fun too but
it was a bad movie yeah it would i
i'm not gonna say no yeah
you were
it was fun though it was it was dope it
was different it was my first time i
ever did something like that it was cool
seeing shia labeouf
um like you didn't like him
he was crazy we had that [ __ ] remember
like that's right he won the fight like
he was so in character he would like
fight fight yeah i've heard he's like
like he tried fighting like this
on the table yes
do you remember when they had to cut
because he cut his hand because so he
was in a gang there's another guy in
another gang and we're at [ __ ] craft
service i'm eating like [ __ ] chicken
tenders and he attacks the guy from the
other gang dude no we're not like he's
cute he's not the camera he's
he's like the stuff i'm sitting down and
they start fighting and they're like
brian break it up [ __ ] like and my [ __ ]
they're playing touch [ __ ] in the park
touched by the party then i was like
trying to kill them and then the next
day they try to keep them away from each
other and we're all pissed off because
he these two keep looking at each other
and we're like come on man like we just
want to get the scene
because
stop the shoots
oh for sure they have to like get his
angle this angle this angle
yeah you're like [ __ ] narcissus
yeah
it was hard man yeah and then sure
enough but we had a [ __ ] long ass day
so
this [ __ ] turns around and he
starts talking [ __ ] to the guy and [ __ ]
it we snap and [ __ ] slam that
[ __ ] on the table and then you
try to hit me like with the gun
and it went like this and it hit conejo
in the mouth remember
i was like it was pissed yeah so i was
holding his hands and i was like choke
him out
and connell was choking him like hey
what the [ __ ] is going on bro this is
shia labeouf
yeah alex baldwin had some issue with
him doing a play on broadway where he
was like i didn't understand at the
point at that time you know i don't know
[ __ ] about he's a method actor dude yeah
yeah i don't understand why he's got a
real tattoo
yeah got his character's name tattooed
on his really stomach yeah i was like
you know this movie like 18 on rotten
tomatoes right
like and you have a tattoo yeah yeah
that's crazy
and you have to keep the same energy the
whole time yeah it's like getting ready
for this
day i was solid that was your first
acting
yeah yeah
yeah that's a real tattoo oh my god
that's him off keto he was on keto on
set oh there you go he blew up
right there with the with the glasses
yeah yeah that was when he was on that's
when he was
remember when he put that bag on his
head and was like i'm not a celebrity
anymore
oh those are real man like chin if you
google like mark harley shyla buff there
might have been like a movie player that
i was in where like i did something
similar
that's how you
did it was crazy to me see how talented
he was remember spoiler alert movies
been out for four years to suck my dick
remember when he uh when he had to die
in the movie and they had to keep
recreating the scene when he gets shot
negro was shooting him and i uh shooting
him and then he has to pretend he's dead
i wasn't there that day he went there
that's the final scene dude seeing him
act like that i was like holy [ __ ] he is
a good actor
and to see him do it over and over and
they'd be like from the hungover games
premiere how many times some articles
got written about it because
they're like the same scene
for 12 hours oh acting is terrible it
was awful you've been in a couple movies
now right um
no not only that one uh it was i did a
or like a part of la originals okay yeah
that and then i just did one with uh i
take it easy no no no no no no
they call me no i know it's like a boxer
it's like a boxer thing
uh with uh
yes but you can have but you but but
brian can have mark uh the the that the
guy from wahlberg yes oh no
i i don't know names but no no i don't
know his name bro mark walter i like
[ __ ] mark he's like
[Applause]
i feel you like i don't know anyone i
just know you by who you played like
when [ __ ] uh like rdj that mickey
ward guy
uh
he was a fan and they hit me hey rdj
wants to talk to you what the [ __ ] like
rafael dosan like what the [ __ ] is rdj
uh robert downey jr oh wow
so i'm just talking about iron man yes
that's nice yeah okay so i'm in the
garage working out and they said okay
he's gonna face him what the [ __ ] i like
ten percent battery i don't know also
who faces it yeah they face i mean i was
like oh
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] iron man i was like
hey what's up bro like oh hi or he's
giving you advice for like a fight or
something no just talking because you
actors are so [ __ ] god he's like all
right bro i've been watching a lot of
your video yeah he was he was cool bro
he was just like i want to get to know
you and everything oh weird and then uh
get to know that
he was like where are you from i'm 28
bro
like say make a wish
i thought it was cool like
i felt so special i felt special he
reshot because he was a fan yes that's
dope and then uh
so [ __ ] get to know you those little
we both we both spent the night in the
same jail station before so we kind of
bonded off that
different reasons though right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah this was for some uh
you know mine was my super [ __ ] his was
really stupid uh those were back in the
days though dude he fully reinvented
himself he's crashing uh yeah but yeah
it's some tough days anyways
yeah i feel you my point uh yeah great
story though